[Music]
we shall call you
Pinocchio
Mexican director Guillermo del Toros
Pinocchio is the latest adaptation of
the classic children's story of a wooden
boy whose nose grows when he lies
[Music]
New York's Museum of Modern Art is
giving visitors the chance to see the
care and craft behind making the movie
in an exhibition fittingly called
crafting Pinocchio
unlike most modern animations Pinocchio
was made not with computer generated
Graphics but with traditional stop
animation techniques a painstaking
process in which the movie is literally
made frame by frame there are eight
full-scale animation sets from the film
just as I appeared this is the largest
one this is the fascist re-education
camp
we've installed one of the studio
cameras and it's taking one still image
at a time between each still image the
Animas would move all the puppets and
then take one photograph and when you
run it all together you've got a the
scene up to 40 animators worked
simultaneously on Pinocchio often at
home during the pandemic the scenes that
last just a few seconds sometimes took
months to make life is such a wonderful
gift although the results are stunning
[Music]
movie is set in fascist Italy in the
1930s and visitors can also see the
designer's attention to detail in
recreating scenes from that era as well
as some of the monsters as fantasy mixes
with reality
Rose Pinocchio
won that category in the Golden Globes
but this exhibition here at the MoMA is
about a lot more than just recognizing
the director the show ends with a board
with all the collaborators photographs
everyone who worked on this film I think
when people leave and see the faces of
the people that created what they've
just experienced it'll be inspiring for
them
an exhibition that's as much about those
who made the art as the art itself
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York